[Music]
new here noon today fireworks lit up the
sky last night it was a beautiful show
as
resorts world celebrated its grand
opening it's expected to be a busy
weekend there it was pretty busy last
night
victoria zaha shares what guests are
saying about the strip's newest property
i'm here at resorts world it's the talk
of the town and the talk on social media
it opened late last night bringing in a
huge crowd
and there was a vegas style welcome with
fireworks now there's a lot to see at
this property
and it really has something for everyone
and different price points between the
rooms and restaurants
there's also a 5.5 acre pool complex as
well as a spa
there are several bars a sports bar
inside a country bar
roderick best is visiting for dallas he
is waiting until tonight to check out
everything that the resort's world has
to offer
the line was around the corner and then
some so
tonight hopefully get there early so get
to get the opportunity to see them the
hype was crazy i seen ads all throughout
the city
and there was like people even this
hotel i'm staying there suggesting it
best did not know about the opening
until he got to las vegas
and says when he comes back he wants to
stay at resorts world
while majority of the resort is open
finishing touches are still being done
to the day club and
nightclub which is expected to open next
weekend
and the theater will be open in november
reporting from resorts world victoria
saha 8 news now